it's already been nearly three years as
the death of fast and furious star Paul
Walker and he would have turned 43 this
week so young so talented and what an
incredible guy Paula truly the heart of
the whole Fast & Furious movie franchise
and he left behind two brothers who
could barely hold back the tears
remembering him you ever feel his
presence down do you ever feel like he's
he's around watching over you absolutely
absolutely
whenever I go surfing whenever I go
fishing whenever I go spearfishing I
think I am 100% synonymous with the
ocean that was he's known for the car
thing from Furious 7 and he loved cars
but the ocean is where he was at like
any moment if he you know any spare
moment he had always wanted to be a
marine biologist like that was like his
dream you know in acting they got away
without you my friend and I'll tell you
about it when I see you after their
brother Paul died in a car crash in 2013
Cody and Caleb Walker paid him a special
kind of tribute filling in for critical
scenes in Furious 7 let's talk about the
processor say you guys worked on the
film for three months how did that work
a lot of it was the angles it really was
a lot of a million to first off we had
about six weeks to put weight on because
when Paul right before Paul passed away
and when you film in that movie he he
got real big we both put on about 12
pounds first off we had to do that we
each have like a little bit of each
other like I have really nice ears and
his ears stick out from the side of his
head so when they when they get they
when they do straight on a Caleb you
know they had a tape his ears Matt
producers used 3d imaging and even
recreated Paul's tattoo with the name of
his daughter on their forearm in that
first day they're like okay now we got
to put the tattoo on and we're sitting
there looking at each other we're like
you could go oh man
like this is
getting emotional thinking about it but
he loved that tattoo it is really really
cool
with Meadows name on it and had a
hibiscus flowers and whatnot and it was
really weird having to rock that thing
for the first the first first while was
really weird and then I mean we both had
it for for the three months and then by
the end of the three months I was like I
think I'd really like to get a tattoo
there nearly three years after his death
Cody and Caleb told me they're still
overwhelmed by the impact of their work
in Paul's final scene yeah we didn't
know the magnitude of like how powerful
it would be until we saw it at the
premiere and we both sat there and cried
for about five minutes before we got got
up out of our seat they did it that well
[Music]
and Cody and Caleb are so committed to
carrying on Paul's legacy they're
holding a fundraiser for his charity
which is reach out worldwide the events
called
game for Paul we're now giveaways like
we've got like Xbox ones you know the
new swag systems that's a great event
for a great cause
and make sure you check it out tomorrow
it is streaming live